I love him in he's my boyfriend way but
I've always loved him it's just I just
love him you know I'm so excited for you
first of all it's amazing use your head
space right now knowing that you have
worked on this for almost a year and
that's about to go into the world oh my
god I mean I'm I'm so excited it really
feels like I'm having a child yeah your
second baby my second my second child
yeah yeah it feels super emotional for
me I mean it just feels like this is
like this chapter in my life that I'm
basically closing and like giving to
people you know and it just feels like
whenever I listen back to the album it
feels so emotionally charged because my
life is in those songs cuz I can't
breathe
I don't know every time I finish an
album it feels like I'm kind of like
putting a bow on it and just like ending
that chapter and and going for the next
one you know yeah and so yeah that's
what this album is to me it's the phase
in my life where I mean I probably will
always be like that but just consumed by
like love and life and the intensity of
those experiences you know like being in
your 20s and and feeling all those
things for the first time is intense and
feel like that's what this album is to
me
[Music]
I love that you co-wrote every single
song on this album I mean that's
something to be so proud of what are we
going to learn about you through these
lyrics end and these words that I'm
dramatic but your email
you know I think that every everybody
like I guess when they start dating or
falling in love or experiencing those
things they can just be like a very
tumultuous time especially like the
first time that you I mean I think every
time you fall in love but I think like
being in your early 20s and like
becoming like an adult and finding your
way in the world and finding you know
your way as your own person and you know
in relation to another person that you
really love yeah I think that people are
just gonna feel how I guess like an
intensely I felt those things
what do you feel like you've learned
about romance and love while making this
album because you said that sort of
making this was in real time yeah um I
don't know I feel like I've learned that
you know ironically like I feel like so
many of these songs are about being in
love and about like how you feel about
another person but I think the biggest
thing I've learned is that the romance
like you really have to just you know as
cliche as it sounds you have to really
love yourself and know yourself first
which is so ironic that I feel like this
album kind of led me back to as well as
that the most important relationship
that you'll ever have is actually the
one with yourself and then it comes the
ones with with other people
you did write this song and it's my
favorite song on the album called use to
this yeah thank you so good and it's
about a trip that you took to San
Francisco with a certain mr. I think
Shawn Mendes no what was it about that
trip that inspired you to come back and
just write that so quickly well I'm just
gonna say I cannot confirm or deny cuz I
don't want people to start telling me oh
this song is idea because then I'm gonna
have to start I've had to was in the
lyric book huh his tattoo there's a
picture of it okay yeah well it's just a
little hint I can't confirm or deny but
anyway uh I mean I think that song is
really special because I just feel like
I really painted the details of you know
like when you're first dating someone
that you've been friends with for a
really long time and it just feels like
oh my god like we're we're kissing now
and it's you know I think I just really
captured what that moment felt like for
me we have seen you kissed a little bit
but at first people were wondering like
is this real is this not real was that
kind of annoying for you not really no
because I know he NASA yeah it doesn't
really honestly did not cause any
emotional reaction for me whatsoever
post on your Instagram I love you to him
is this love and what's like the first
romantic thing I mean I thought I mean
i-i've said that oh I've said that a lot
I mean as I do obviously like I love him
in he's my boyfriend way but I've always
loved him as just I just love him you
know
[Music]
how do you feel like you've evolved as
an artist from the first record to this
record and what is your musical journey
look like like what's your place in the
music industry I think I've just learned
to trust myself more and I think just
really knowing like what I'm doing it
for you know because I think like the
more I do this the more I'm I I don't
know I feel really in touch with like
what writing does for me especially on
this album like it was just like a very
healing thing and a very like cathartic
thing for like a lot of the experiences
that I went through like writing these
songs was like my way of kind of staying
in touch with with my emotions and just
feeling it and not trying to even figure
it out until actually which I can do
sometimes when I'm not in the studio I
kind of like go more to my head and I
think like when I'm writing I like I'm
just feeling and I'm just like very in
touch with my emotions and so I think
that's I guess a really important part
of just being an artist is just knowing
like at the root of everything like I
know that making these songs is for me
but given that it's it's my my sanity
[Music]
the live show I'm so excited but yeah
yeah all the dates
y'all of them what my day yeah what do
you have in store for us like how do you
visualize this romance album playing out
well I think with all of my I mean I
just really want to take people to just
another world like I feel like concerts
for me and and music and and visuals
especially or a form of just escapism to
me and and really getting to go to a
show and go on a journey and like kind
of leave reality that's that's what I
want to do on stage that's what I want
to do for my fans too but it's gonna be
so much fun because I have the most fun
on stage like being able to and you're
so good on stage oh thank you that's a
good presents about you Thanks that's so
nice but yeah my situs would just kind
of like reach out and be able to see
people saying these words like I think
that's gonna be really magical for me